No culpable así se declaró el
expresidente Donald Trump Este martes en
una corte de Miami la víspera de sus 77
aniversario Trump compareció en la corte
donde se le presentaron formalmente los
37 cargos que se le imputan el gobierno
estadounidense lo acusa de violar a la
ley de espionaje entre otras al retirar
a documentos clasificados tras abandonar
a la oficina oval señalamientos que ha
negado en todo momento
creo que está yendo genial creo que esto
está amañado tenemos un país amañado que
no tiene fronteras tenemos un país que
no tiene más que problemas somos una
nación en decadencia
además de estar en medio de varios
procesos judiciales Trump acaba de
iniciar su campaña para reelegirse como
favorito en las primarias republicanas
de 2024 e intentar regresar a la casa
blanca a finales del mismo año algo que
Aunque parezca que puede dañar su
reputación ha reforzado el mensaje
político de anti starlishment entre sus
seguidores
Trump estamos acá por ti No dejes que te
roben no te retires No te rindas a pesar
de ser el primer ex presidente en la
historia del país en enfrentar cargos
criminales Trump haya asegurado que
planea presentarse sea cual sea el
resultado de los procesos judiciales en
su contra